[Music]
one of the questions that we're all
asking now is what effect are the new
technologies of the internet Computers
cell phone screens going to have on the
next generation of children and the
answer is we won't know for another 20
years until those children grow up but I
think we can make some guesses based on
our past human history and one of the
things about human beings is that we've
been technological beings from the very
beginning in fact in a way that's the
thing that's most distinctive about us
we use tools we modify and change our
environments we we create new ways of
being in the world both physically and
socially and that's what we've always
done and we've always changed we've
always had culture which enabled us to
take the inventions of one generation
and then modify or change them to suit
another generation so the fact that we
have technology and the fact that that
technology changes and it changes across
generations none of that's new but
curiously part of the effect of that
cultural change is it always seems as if
the technology that we grew up with is
eternal it's just part of nature it has
always been there and the technology
that our children come up with is part
of a dystopian Mad Max future apocalypse
and that's also been true for as long as
we've been around as human beings so
many of the technologies that you could
argue really did have transformative
effects on us are things like the
printing press the Telegraph the Train
we don't think about a telegraph as
being any amazingly disruptive new
technology but when Telegraph's and
trains were introduced there were just
as many editorials in the paper saying
this these are awful ideas they're going
to reshape our lives in ways that are
going to be completely destructive of of
human happiness now in some ways that's
right I mean the printing press really
did completely change the way that we
related to the world and related to each
other
The Telegraph meant that we went from
communicating at the speed of a fast
horse to communicating at the speed of
light that made an enormous change in
the way that we functioned and related
to one another
I think it's quite plausible that things
like the Internet are also going to make
it a change in the way that we think the
way we relate to one another but the
assumption that somehow this time it's
different this is going to be the change
that's going to destroy our brains or
destroy our minds it doesn't really fit
our history and it doesn't fit what we
know from neuroscience and psychology
about the way that childhood is this
kind of cold rain of innovation so one
of the reasons why we have this effect
this kind of ratchet this sense that the
technological change in our generation
is totally different than any of the
others is that there's a big difference
between the way we learn with an adult
brain and the way we learn with a
child's brain so for adults say learning
a new skill demands tremendous amounts
of attention and energy and working
memory we have to put a lot of work into
learning how to do something new so when
I have to figure out how to use my cell
phone for example
it feels effortful I mean is effortful
and distracting that's very different
though from what happens with the skills
that we learn when we're in the first
couple of years of life things like
learning to speak or even learning to
read when I walk through a crowded
Street full of billboards I don't feel
as if I'm constantly being distracted
because I have to decode what all those
letters are all those billboards mean
and that's because I learned to do that
it's such a young age that it literally
just takes place automatically without
higher-level
control and it seems plausible that that
for a new generation of children who are
interacting with devices from the time
their babies with touch and voice that
kind of interaction will be as natural
and spontaneous for them as reading is
for me now they'll be different it won't
be the same as reading because
interacting with a screen is different
from reading but I don't see any
particular reason to believe that that's
going to be the terrible evil technology
as opposed to all the other technologies
Socrates famously said that reading was
a terrible idea
books were not a good idea because first
of all they would destroy our ability to
do things like memorize all of the works
of Homer and secondly if you had a book
you would think that what was written in
the book was true and
engaging in a Socratic dialogue with the
information in the book and you know
Socrates was right about both those
things no one nowadays has a memory
that's good enough to memorize homer and
we do tend to things think that things
and books are are true and we can't
interrogate them the same way we could
in conversation but overall by and large
the benefits outweighed the outweigh the
harms and I think that's going to be
true for the new technologies that we're
grappling with now
[Music]